hello good afternoon we begin with news
of an extraordinary medical development
that could change the lives of people
living with spinal cord injuries
scientists in Geneva have pioneered new
technology which allows wireless
communication between the brain and the
spinal cord allowing paralyzed patients
to walk again
well this is Gert Jan oskam who has been
paralyzed for 12 years after he broke
his neck in a cycling accident implants
the size of SIM cards were placed in his
brain over the areas that control
movements one side for the left leg the
other for the right
a computer powered with artificial
intelligence then interpreted his brain
signals and sent an instruction
wirelessly to a second device that was
implanted in his lower back bringing the
damage Bridging the damage to the spinal
cord
electrical impulses were then sent to
coordinate his leg muscles allowing him
to walk
came into the hospital in the
Netherlands for the first time after I
broke my neck
I was hoping Taylor offered me a system
like this but there was nothing so
um I was a bit disappointed when I
arrived in the Netherlands and they told
me you will never walk again anymore we
we can't help you
and I think with this system uh yeah I
can only wish it was happening me uh to
me 12 years ago but uh I'm still pleased
that uh
I have it now
well this is quite simply extraordinary
I mean you know you use that word a lot
but this is a case where it's totally
justified this south side it's a medical
correspondent Thomas Moore to tell us
more about it we see him walking there
through essentially SIM cards in his
brain and is connected to his spine it's
just wow isn't it I mean he has a a
severe injury to his spinal cord and his
neck after a really nasty cycling
accident more than 10 years ago but now
they've managed to to bridge that damage
they've reconnected his brain to his
muscles and allowed him to walk again to
take a step again to climb stairs and it
is quite extraordinary to watch the
video yes his walking is not fluent
fluid it is is hesitant and it's slow uh
and he drags his feet but imagine the
transformation for someone who is in a
chair a wheelchair because of a
paralysis who can't even stand and and
look somebody directly in the eyes at
their at their level and he can do all
that now he can stand at the bar with
his mates and have a beer and look them
in the eye and he says for that it's a
psychological and a physical thing and
it is because it's extraordinary
technology that they have been able to
decode that jumble of brain signals from
the part of the brain that controls
muscles but can't get through the spinal
cord at the moment and then with
artificial intelligence turn that into
electronic signals that wirelessly go
back into the spinal cord and coordinate
the very complex muscle movement that
leads to walking quite extraordinary and
the doctors have been working it on it
in ilizan in in Switzerland believe that
this is a transformation for people
living with paralysis and I spoke to
them earlier today
yeah we believe this is a real
breakthrough here it's not controlling
robots it's really reconnecting two
regions of the central nervous system
that are disconnected this is like the
true digital revolution in terms of
Prosthetics it's a completely new Dogma
that is starting with the of course a
proof of principle only one patient but
it shows us that it's not science
fiction anymore and that a new era for
these people that New Hope can be given
to people with a spinal cord injury
well it could quite literally change the
lives of you know hundreds of thousands
of people who are affected by similar
injuries but at what stage are we at
with this Thomas in terms of is this
just the initial stages when can you
know people at home affected perhaps get
involved in this yeah just on the
numbers 50 000 people in the UK alone
living with spinal injuries and that
goes up by two and a half thousand years
wrap that up worldwide into a lot of
people as you say and they're optimistic
that it could even be used for people
who are paralyzed through stroke and
that's a whole new category with many
thousand more so they are trying to roll
this out but you can imagine this is
going to be expensive technology and
there is some disquiet among the amongst
people who are disabled from spinal cord
injuries that it'd be better to spend
money on helping them adapt to life as
they know it rather than Reinventing the
technology to allow them something which
is difficult to regain they've already
made the adjustment to a wheelchair
better to help them to live well in that
chair so it's controversial but
nevertheless take nothing away from the
extraordinary stride taken through this
technology interesting stuff yeah that's
an interesting angle actually like you
said some people have been living with
the injury for so long they don't want
the change I mean a lot will come with
that in terms of you know adapting uh to
walk again and in that sense what
happens next to us where does it go from
here so that they hope that this is just
going to develop they they believe that
they can improve the implants the
artificial intelligence will get better
at decoding brain signals and the hope
will be that you will get that uh fluid
motion that most of us don't even think
about when we walk but for him uh Gert
yarn he's having to think about every
movement left leg right leg left leg
right leg and is very deliberate uh and
it's not subconscious in the way that we
would see it and that is the challenge
to help people really adapt uh to life
back on their two feet once again yeah
uh Thomas remarkable stuff we're talking
about it throughout the course of the
program this afternoon uh thank you so
much Thomas More there with the latest